the texans
will be hiring
nick casario
to be their general manager no this is
not a lost
episode from june of 2019 when the
texans tried to hire nick casario and
had the door slammed in their face by
the patriots they are finally getting
him almost two years later and when they
didn't hire him
see here's how it went
they wanted him june of 2019. this was
jack easterby's white whale
and they tried to get him
and the patriots blocked it and the
patriots accused used to be of tampering
because there was supposedly a
conversation between easter b and
casario at the ring ceremony because
easter be had been a patriots employee
so that all stopped the texans backed
off and then we thought well once the
2019 season ends that's when
they're going to go hire nick casario
and then they didn't they made bill
o'brien the general manager then they
fire bill o'brien in the 2020 season
ends and now they have casario's the gm
along the way they they've paid corn
ferry somewhere between a hundred
thousand and a million dollars to be the
search firm on this chris and cassario
wasn't one of their finalists
you can't make this stuff up
they paid corn ferry somewhere between a
hundred thousand dollars and a million
dollars to to find the candidates for
the job corn ferry identified five
finalists and nick casario wasn't one of
them and they've hired nick casario
advantage
easter bee
definitely i mean yes all that other
stuff corn ferry a few hundred thousand
dollars is just to
you know appease the nfl the media the
fan base whatever just to make it look
like it but you know the way that goes
down and especially the fact that you're
like you're right i mean he's not on the
list of five people
that just tells you that this was the
plan all along and that easter bee and
everybody you know
cal mcnair everybody involved that knew
that this was going this way but they
wanted to put their best foot forward
and act like okay hey we're doing this
you know so i i mean i'm not mad at them
i'm not i don't understand why you don't
just add nick casario into the list of
names that you're interviewing anyways
to make it look a little bit more
inconspicuous i guess to say there but
either way
um i'll say this much you know i have
great respect for nick casario i think
this is a great hire about the houston
texans football team you know the things
you worried about with jack easterby and
all that what does he know about
football and all that well great he
doesn't need to know anything anymore
because nick casario knows it all nick
casario is going to be great to get an
organization who doesn't seem to have a
clear plan right now about where their
team or roster is going casario has
learned from a master has the ultimate
process and will scorch earth to find
players and that's where it'll be good
for houston
two things yeah
first of all right
cassario is going to know his place as
it relates to easter be sure his
scenario is going to let easter be do
his thing you know it's possible to get
a guy who allows you to still run the
show who will be good at the job what
easter bee was trying to avoid was
somebody who comes in and says
hey you
get the hell out of here all right
you're not part of the football
operation
go go sell raffle tickets right go have
a bake sale you have nothing to do with
a football operation if i see you around
here again i'm going to whip your ass
that's what easter bee wanted to avoid
the other side of it
chris
look
i
you're talking like the the patriots
have been
experts when it comes to rounding up
great players i mean i hear look the
texans need receivers well here comes
nick casario from the team that doesn't
know how to draft or develop a wide
receiver is this a good fit right now
with deshaun watson there was that
cryptic tweet from deshaun watson last
night some things never changed and i'm
thinking hey he should be happy nick
casario is coming from new england first
of all who from new england especially
on the executive level has ever done
anything in the nfl other than thomas
dimitrov and second look at the recent
history of drafting and developing young
players i don't know that i would have
hired nick casario uh but but what the
the other stuff of the last like 10 12
years of just building a team that's the
best in football every year after year
after year that doesn't count i mean i
don't understand we're just going to go
one year ago
well it's been great for matt patricia
and bob quinn okay
that's the thing all right john robinson
robinson's executive has been successful
nick saban's been successful like
they're all part of the tree yeah
there's been some failures brian flores
is kicking butt right now i mean so yes
i know there was failures i get that oh
i was getting ready for the playoffs
right now well 10 and six and turned
around and was in the coaching
conversation i think you drafted them
last week in the coach of the year
conversation and i thought they were
going to make the playoffs okay but it's
still there but okay now
all right yeah i know it's not the
greatest roster in new england this year
and new england's never been a team
about building a team of superstars
that's not what they are they decide to
go the route of for the most part let's
get a lot of good players and have
incredible depth and versatility so no
matter what team we play our genius
coach
will
find the right formula within the
versatility and the depth we player to
screw that team over instead of just
going we're going to make this unit
awesome and unstoppable and to that yes
the draft hasn't been great but damn i
don't know i mean you know gronkowski
and edelman and all the other free agent
signings and amendola have also been
awesome and the chris hogans of the
world too that way so i understand what
you're saying but i think you can't
judge nick casario just off of this last
year
and
you know one year of football when
they've made nine million great moves
throughout that time and just forget
about that
he was he was he was the the director
player personnel when they drafted aaron
hernandez that's a different story
altogether so look
there's always going to be swings and
misses there's always going to be good
things and bad things that you can point
to and the one challenge i think
for anyone who's been
in that
in that crock pot with bill belichick
for that much time
when you leave
how much of you
genuinely you is what emerges and how
much of you have been changed even if
you don't realize it by constant
exposure to bill belichick because there
are negative aspects of the bill
belichick persona that can creep into
you the socially awkward curmudgeon
right how much of that has infected the
way that nick casario interacts with the
world that's what's going to be
interesting because some
some come out intact sure others
come out
completely
dna altered
to be
like bill belichick when they weren't
and they shouldn't be and it's only
going to work for you if you win and i
don't have any reason to believe cassero
is going to be that way but he was there
a long time yeah right he was there a
long time no he didn't so we'll see
right you're right we'll see he he he is
uh of that mold he is a semi curmudgeon
but i mean that in a good way the fact
that it's just it's ball all day long
that's what he does football football
football football he's not going to be
about charming your pants off or being
johnny charisma or doing anything like
that but he's going to be honest very
straightforward no bs he's going to lay
out what he sees as a vision for the
football team that's where it'll be good
too and i'll say this mike just in my
experience there just to show you a
little bit because yeah of course he's
gonna take a lot of what he had for
belichick but i can just say
like the two drafts i witnessed i don't
think he necessarily agreed with every
draft pick belichick made i don't think
so you were locked in a closet no i was
locked in a closet that was right
outside the draft room so i got to see
who was walking in and out of that room
and when they were happy or not happy
and i know we made a few pics that day
where i went nick casario walked out and
shook his head like i don't know if i
like that pic either way so he's going
to have a mind of his own too it won't
be just like you know copy everything
bill belichick did
uh one last point before we take a break
keep your eyes now on brian dayball as
the next coach of the houston texans i'm
not saying it's going gonna happen but
it makes sense that's that's the one to
watch moving forward we're gonna take a
break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports